Das war's für heute.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
so irgendwie ist mein sound auf einem ohr nicht an was ist da los moment glaube ich
meine zeit abstöpseln wieder anstöpseln so jetzt ja jetzt besser exzellent ja auf geht's
also johnny hat eine dvd fragt wie kann ich am besten mobiles internet vom handy also das
da was wie kann ich am besten mobiles internet vom handy ins lan einspeisen gibt es da ein usb
ja ja ja gibt es jeder normale lade adapter zumindest zumindest beim iphone ist das so kannst
ein iphone per ganz normal per lade usb lade adapter an rechner anschließen und dann kannst
du dein iphone ich hab tatsächlich gesagt noch nie gemacht aber ich weiß dass es funktioniert
dann kannst du dein iphone als netzwerkgerät verwenden dass das funktioniert was auch geht
was wahrscheinlich die bessere variante ist was auch auf jeden fall mit android funktioniert
ist du kaufst den billigen access point den im kleinen modus betreibst ne pizze lustig
ich glaube es geht ihm umgedreht darum der will das händler will das der will sein seine
mobilfunkverbindung von seinem rechner aus verwenden so hätte ich das jetzt verstanden
also wenn die fritzbox irgendwie mal was spezielles kann was weiß ich keine ahnung hab ich schon
nie ausprobiert von der logik her das einfachste dürfte sein jetzt aber unabhängig von irgendwelchen
spezialgeschichten die vielleicht eine fritzbox machte nicht das einfachste dürfte wahrscheinlich
möglich sein man nimmt sich den access point vielleicht kann man eine fritzbox nehmen soweit
das funktioniert keine ahnung packt das ganze in klein modus connectet sich zum wlan shared
wlan access point was auch immer wie heißt das nochmal also man kann doch man kann doch
auf seinem hotspot also man kann doch auf seinem händli einen hotspot aufmachen womit
man dann quasi alle die in diesem hotspot drin sind das internet beziehungsweise die lte 3g 5g
was auch immer verbindung benutzen können ja und man könnte sich einfach einen client access point
nehmen ein access point den man in klein modus packt und den meldet man am hotspot an und das
war's und dann kannst du dich auch bei 45 an den client modus stöpseln das geht ja auch also wenn
es dir möglich um netzmer kabel geht und noch viel besser du kannst einfach diesen du kannst
einfach diesen client access point nehmen und einen switch stecken und gut ist per kabel ja dann
musst du dann kannst du dich per usb anschließt das habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert keine ahnung
also ich weiß dass wenn du den handy also wenn du ein iphone nimmst und stöpselst das an rechner
an dann meldet sich das als unter linux zumindest als netzwerkarte an ich habe keine ahnung wie
das mit android geräten ist wahrscheinlich ähnlich und unter windows wird es wahrscheinlich auch
funktionieren
oder man das ist natürlich auch nicht schlecht wenn man direkt an die fritzbox stecken kann aber das
habe ich wie gesagt das habe ich noch nicht aus mit keine ahnung usb smartphone fritzbox das
habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert fritzbox ja und siehst du guck mal das ist so viel einfacher
es ist noch einfacher vorausgesetzt man hat eine fritzbox ansonsten dürfte die geschichte mit
client mod access point am einfachsten sein weil dann gilt das schlicht und ergreifend auch direkt
für alle da können das alle rechner im lokalen netzwerk verwenden weil es halt answitch gesteckt
werden könnte funktioniert jetzt ja glaube ich dir musste das geht doch mit dem iphone bestimmt
auch oder auch obwohl hier android steht das geht doch bestimmt mit dem das geht doch bestimmt mit
einem iphone auch ja das wäre natürlich die aller einfachste variante wenn es schon was
eingebautes in der fritzbox gibt dann würde ich das wahrscheinlich auch nehmen iphone keck
w warum ihr keck weight warum android ich sage immer wieder das hat alles seine vorteile es hat
überhaupt keinen sinn sich da drüber zu streiten was jetzt irgendwie besser ist ich glaube eine
sache auf die wir uns alle einigen können das einzige was echt geht nicht mit einem iphone ok
haben wir haben wir ich meine wir haben so einen wir haben so einen anti ja ja war im mod irgendwie
aber wir haben kein apple mod apple mod gibt so was keck keck wie apple man bräuchte man bräuchte
mal irgendwie ein gutes emote wo man sich über apple aus dem machen kann wenn es gerade nichts
gutes zu ein man könnte man könnte den den den den den was war das denn diese käsereibe von apple
sieht echt aus wie eine käsereibe oder also ich finde es hat es hat echt was von der käsereibe
das ist halt apple apple make pro käsereibe das haben wirklich leute ausprobiert ja aber
ansonsten fällt mir kein passendes apple null emote ein was ist heute geplant eigentlich nur
eine sache oder noch nicht mal noch nicht mal geplant also ich hatte ich muss ich muss ich
hatte die auswahl jetzt entweder weil ich bin ja zu mehr oder weniger hier mit mit rum räumen
und so fertig ja und das schöne ist ja ich hatte ja ich macht es mal weg dass das verwirrt bestimmt
dir so viele leute ja ich habe mit rum räumen aufgehört jetzt es reicht jetzt und ich habe
ja noch frei also heute morgen montag und ich hatte jetzt die wahl entweder mache ich den stream
an musik geht mir gerade ein bisschen auf den sack
zumindest was wollte ich jetzt sagen ich kriege gerade kein gescheites als raus
genau also wie gesagt habe ich seit drei tagen frei und ich habe jetzt die ausfall entweder
mache ich stream an oder ich fange den neuen pass of exile karakter an wollte ich ich meine
ich habe nur einen main farm karakter ich wollte schon die ganze zeit mal einen zweiten machen und
das wollte ich jetzt eigentlich mal so ich hatte die ausfall zwischen ich mach das oder ich mach
stream an deswegen habe ich gesagt ich mache jetzt einfach mal kurz stream an und wir gucken uns
was anderes wichtiges an und dann spiele ich nachher eine runde pass of exile und wenn wenn
ihr wollt kann ich den char sogar im stream anfangen allerdings weiß ich dass es nicht all zu viele
interessiert deswegen bin ich mir nicht ganz sicher aber ich will mir auf jeden fall noch
einen neuen neuen char machen den ich versuche so schnell wie es geht irgendwie durch die kampagne
zu zu schleusen ich habe mir ein paar krasse pass of exile speedrun tricks abgeguckt mal gucken wie
gut ich das exekuted kriege wahrscheinlich gar nicht aber ich hoffe mal dass ich so in
keine ahnung sechs sieben stunden oder so vielleicht der kampagne das schaffe ich
wahrscheinlich keine ahnung mal gucken mal gucken so zumindest andere wichtige sache wo
wir jetzt mal ganz schnell gucken müssen nehmen wir noch ein paar anderen sachen
ja bei der wei bevor ich bevor ich da von anfangen wisst ihr wisst ihr was wieder aktuell extrem
rassistisch ist habe ich habe ich heute irgendwo gelesen körperteile sind neuerdings extrem rassistisch
habe ich heute auf irgendeiner newsseite gesehen körperteile und zwar weil ich finde die sache
immer lustig weil er hat sich irgendeine feministin darüber aufgeregt dass körperteile ja alle nach
männer benannt wären die sie entdeckt haben ja saurei aber auch was was haben sich die typen
nur erlaubt irgendwelche körperteile und organe zu entdecken und krankheiten vielleicht auch und
das geht aber nicht ja ich meine zum beispiel wo sie sich richtig darüber aufgeregt haben ist
dass die achilles sehne ist es glaube ich dass die achilles sehne achilles sehne heißt weil
achilles ist ja ein kerl und dass das nach einem mann benannt ist das geht ja überhaupt nicht
wir müssen das jetzt alles umbenennen also die ich hab echt das gefühl es gibt einfach zu wenig
probleme die wir haben ja das hat das habe ich auch gesehen skill killer wir haben einfach zu
wenig probleme ich finde das thema an sich gar nicht so verkehrt ja man kann sich da durchaus
mal gedanken darüber machen aber die schreiben das immer so absolut alles so nach dem motto so
ich decke jetzt auf das und das läuft hier falsch könnte man das nicht vielleicht in
der nummer kleiner kochen so nach dem motto okay lasst uns doch mal darüber reden ob da
nicht was falsch läuft körper fucking körperteile wie können körper naja gut was auch immer ja das
habe ich auch gesehen also wer es noch nicht mitbekommen hat christ stonemann es hat überhaupt
kein sound gemacht oder es hat es hat überhaupt kein abo sound gemacht die die musik ist zu
monka es hat mal kurz relaxing game music wir müssen gerade mal kurz was anderes anmachen
relaxing video game musik exzellent das ist schön entspannend übrigens das game habe ich taugt das
game das game hat einen unglaublich geilen soundtrack children children of light ich
kenne das game nicht also nur vor ein paar bildern ich habe nie gespielt hatte ich auch nicht vor
aber das hat ein wirklich sehr angenehm soundtrack ich hätte schon ein paar sachen von gehört so
zumindest wer es noch nicht mitbekommen hat auf github möchten sie jetzt darauf hinwirken
sie wollen es keinem vorschreiben aber sie wollen es quasi so zum neuen man kann nicht sagen zum
neuen default aber zum zum angestrebten default machen dass das dass der aktuelle gith default
branche also wenn man den git repo erstellt gehen wir mal hier rein dass man das hier mal gesehen
haben was um was eigentlich was es da geht um was ich da die leute gerade wieder aufringen und wo
wir wieder bei den punkten ich habe den eindruck also es gibt es gibt wohl nicht aber pippen
please wir haben echt nicht genug probleme und was für einen scheiß wir uns aktuell gedankt machen
ist der wahnsinn so also was es geht ist folgendes auch guck mal es läuft immer noch excellent pp
please ganz davon zu schweigen dass ja mittlerweile hier das ist ja auch schon ein hassymbol und wusste
die übrigens auch dass das dass wusste ich auch noch gar nicht so lange dass das clown emoji dass
das clown face emoji dass das auch ein hassymbol ist mittlerweile du kannst ja fast nichts mehr
verwenden ich kann meinen tanzen in pippen nicht mehr verwenden man darf kein clown emoji verwenden
blick also aktuell es ist unglaublich schwierig überhaupt schritt ja gut das ok emoji das wissen
wir ja mittlerweile alle schon es ist mittlerweile unglaublich schwierig da überhaupt schritt zu
halten was man immer verwenden darf zumindest um was ist ich um was ist ich cute chat um was
ich bei github gerade aufgeregt wird oder bei github ist wenn man in github anlegt github ist
ein versionsverwaltungstool und standardmäßig nach dem erstellen von dem repo
ja also der zeigt noch nichts an weil wir noch nichts kommet haben standardmäßig heißt der
branch master wenn man von master copy eigentlich mal ursprünglich so und und das ist böse
wie hast du den tanzen pippen gemacht hier gif zu einem gif animationstool bringt es
bevor ich hier weiter zu dieser geschichte was sagt der chronn moment ja das wird schon mal
rüber ich sollte vielleicht mal mein fragen lock tool an machen weil dann über sehe ich auch
nichts ich finde es macht mir viel spaß zum zugucken ich gucke gerne zu finde das irgendwie
sehr entspannend zum zugucken aber selber spielen ist nicht mein fall an sich finde ich das spiel
gut ich gucke sehr gern zu und bei riot habe ich auch nicht das gefühl dass sie das morgen
einstellen sie ist in battlefield 5 ja also wo wollte ich jetzt eben noch mal schnell was zu
sagen genau hier mein hauptrouter befindet sich im keller dank unity media und deshalb muss ich
meinen zweitrouter als mesh nehmen warum muss es als mesh sein kannst du mir ein repeater powerline
empfehlen also repeater sind in der regel keine allzu tolle geschichte ja das ist ein problem
also ich weiß dass das problem viele haben das gibt es in unterschiedlichen arten und weisen
entweder ist der router im keller oder aber es ist irgendwie in einem anderen stockwerk wo
eine beton decke dazwischen ist wo nichts durchkommt gut d-laden und powerline das
kommt ja ungefähr aufs gleiche raus das hängt vom haus ab wie gut das ganze funktioniert wie
gut die diese netzwerkgeschichte über stromleitung funktioniert man kann das mal ausprobieren es
gibt häuser da funktioniert das gut ich würde mal sagen mit dem meisten funktioniert es eigentlich
ganz gut bei manchen ist es ein bisschen problematisch dass es entweder gar nicht
richtig funktioniert oder aber wenn man beispielsweise irgendeiner die mikrowelle
einschaltet oder den hert anmacht oder dass das dann rumspackt das kann man das kann man
mal probieren allerdings muss ich sagen an sich ist wlan finde ich besser als sein ruf also
es gibt es gibt mehrere varianten probierst du es optimal mit wlan ordentlich durchkommst
und nicht unbedingt mit einem repeater sondern du nimmst einfach wie ich ganz am anfang vom
stream gesagt habe du nimmst einfach also wenn dein unity media das ist ja eine connect box
oder sowas so ein ding hast dir wahrscheinlich so ein unity media connect box so ein teil wenn
das ding im keller steht also was mehrere varianten entweder vielleicht hast du irgendwie die
varianten mit die möglichkeit oder vielleicht liegt schon ein kabel es ist ja manchmal so
fangen wir mal mit mit den sachen an was man machen kann also entweder liegt vielleicht schon
ein telefonkabel vielleicht liegt schon ein telefonkabel aus dem keller in ersten stock
mit dem telefonkabel kann man was machen weiß ich nicht wie das bei dir aussieht ob das schon
telefonkabel liegt ja also viele leute haben ja auch den telefonanschluss unten im keller
allerdings dann eine the dose im erdgeschoss oder so also wenn du telefonkabel schon hast
damit kann man was machen generell wenn du irgendwelche kabel oder rohre liegen hast zum
beispiel von einer türkigen sprechanlage oder sowas kann man damit auch was machen wenn du
natürlich ein leerrohr hast es optimal da kannst du einfach netzwerkabel durchmachen und gut ist
aber da gehe ich mal von aus das wird nicht so gut funktionieren ja wie sind denn so die
gegebenheiten bei dir wer hat es noch mal gefragt mein wer hat es noch mal gefragt hier von x
kommt ein bisschen auf die gegebenheiten drum herum an so wenn das mit also wie gesagt wenn
du zwei adern hast und also sprich in den telefonkabel reicht dann kann man mit ein
bisschen investition da drüber auch eine netzwerkverbindung machen das funktioniert
wohl ganz gut ansonsten wäre leerrohr hast es natürlich noch viel besser ansonsten wenn
gar nichts anderes funktioniert du kannst mal mit powerline probieren allerdings ich bin der
ansicht dass wlan bei sowas besser ist als sein ruf und man kann das auch mit wlan machen ich
meine wenn deine connectbox unten steht und man dort das standard default unity media wlan anmacht
man kennt man könnte sich auch oben den access point hinstellen im klein modus und drauf
zugreifen und von dort dann halt an den switch und dann per kabel ich habe vom keller in die
zweite etage ein langkabel verlegt und an meine fritzbox angeschlossen ja
aber dann ist doch dann ist doch eigentlich alles gut oder
wenn du schon netzwerkabel hast
wäre es dann nicht wäre es dann nicht einfacher wenn du schon vom keller in den
zweiten etage netzwerkabel hast wäre es dann nicht einfacher entweder noch ein zweites
netzwerkabel vom keller in das erdgeschoss zu machen oder aber wenn das zu schwierig ist
vom zweiten stock in den ersten stock netzwerkabel zu machen und dann irgendwo
einen switch dazwischen zu stellen also da gibt es ja wirklich tausende möglichkeiten
wenn das gaming zimmer im erdgeschoss ist und kabel bleibt ja nur kabel im endeffekt
oder an den access point im klein modus oder dlan oder so aber das ist eigentlich crap also
wenn du schon ein netzwerkabel vom keller in zweiten stock hast dann dürfte das
einfachste sein noch ein zweites netzwerkabel aus dem keller in erdgeschoss oder aber wenn
das zu kompliziert ist weil meistens ja von keller rauszukommen immer schwierig ist vielleicht ist
es auch einfacher das ganze ist in der zweiten etage ja aber dann hast du dann ist doch alles
gut dann wird dann bin ich zu durft da bin ich zu low brain für wenn du doch schon vom keller
wenn du doch schon vom keller im zweiten stock eine netzwerkabel liegen hast wo ist dann das
problem ist das problem von dort wo das netzwerkabel rauskommt wo das gaming zimmer ist
ansonstes habe ich kapiert nicht ganz also sprich die verbindung vom dort wo das kabel
rauskommt im zweiten stock zu wo der pc im gaming zimmer steht die lex kritiker information
ja das stimmt schon he doesn't know so wo will ich euch bei der ganzen geschichte stehen geblieben
ja ich muss erstmal was hast du tipps wenn deine baby katze die ganze zeit an deinem dx racer
kratzen will ja einen ordentlichen büro stuhl holen anstatt den dx racer wobei an dem kratzt
sie auch so ist es nicht aber dx racer ist überhaupt nicht meins gewesen ich hatte ja
auch mal ein hat mir nicht gefallen oder habe ich die ursprüngliche sache nicht kapiert
ok dann habe ich eigentlich nicht kapiert also wenn schon netzwerkabel da ist doch alles
ok naja so das haben wir uns angeguckt genau und das was ich euch hier gerade gezeigt habe
das problem ist woran sich gerade gestört wird dass eben default mäßig da der standard
branche master heißt übrigens kommt es in dem fall weder von sklavenhaltung noch sonst
was sondern angeblich von master copy aber wie dem auch sei darüber wird sich gerade
in der it wahnsinnig in der it welt wahnsinnig aufgeregt deswegen möchte man jetzt master
zu main umbenennen und das sorgt halt für ein paar probleme weil alle tutorials steht
master drin default mäßig viele hooks script sonst was funktioniert mit master man kann
das alles enden man kann das alles ändern ich frage mich nur ob der aufwand ist rechtfertigt
irgendwie dass das zu tun ja wo ist das live branche denn die gibt es in dem fall gar nicht
ist ja noch der witz dabei naja es gibt übrigens ich habe letztens auch irgendwo gesehen eine
anleitung wie man die sachen jetzt wie man jetzt die sachen korrekterweise nennen sollte
so also ja mein zweites router befindet sich im wz was ist denn das wz wc wohnt im wohnzimmer
wohnzimmer jetzt ja jetzt habe ich mein wohnzimmer mein gamingzimmer die krassen abkürzung jetzt
gehts ab mein gamingzimmer möchte ich gerne mit laden betreiben ich weiß halt eben nicht
wie ich das machen kann ohne drinnen ok jetzt habe ich jetzt habe ich kapiert also sprich
das kabel aus dem keller jetzt habe ich kapiert das kabel aus dem keller so krasse krasse
campaign skills kommen jetzt also excel aber da brauchst du kein pain für also das kabel
aus dem keller von der unity media connectbox kommt im wohnzimmer raus und dein gamingzimmer
auf der gleichen etage möchtest du irgendwie an diesen router dran kriegen ha jetzt hab
ich jetzt hab ich kapiert ich gehe davon aus du fragst das weil es keine option ist
ein kabel durch die wand zu bohren oder oder wie einfach kommst du denn vom ja dann ist
natürlich doof das ist natürlich blöd einen switch bringt er ja dann auch nix einen switch
bringt ihm ja dann auch nix den switch bringt ihm ja auch nix der kabel muss er trotzdem
irgendwie anschließen also du kannst mit dlan oder powerline probieren wenn das wenn
das geht ist gut ich denke mal nicht dass da irgendwie eine küche mit mikrowelle oder
was so in der nähe ist hast du die ist liegt liegt denn irgendein anderes kabel vom wohnzimmer
in dein gamingzimmer wichtig ist irgendwelche kabel irgendwelche kabel es ist eigentlich
ziemlich egal welche also es ist keine stromkabel die strom führen ja aber ansonsten ist fast
egal weil du brauchst einfach nur kupferleitung für die entfernung brauchst du wahrscheinlich
gar nicht sonderlich viel da könnte man sicherlich was basteln aber die einfachste variante
dürfte wahrscheinlich wirklich powerline sein weil ich kein großartiger powerline fan bin
ehrlich gesagt oder aber du probierst wirklich mit einem access point im client modus also
ich würde in dem fall eher wlan nehmen du kaufst den billigen access point muss ja kein
guten seien irgendwas irgendwas billiges irgendwie kann tp link etwas ganz billiges so irgendwie
sowas hier irgendwas 28 75 oder so und den stellst du im client modus und meldest dich
im wlan an von der fritzbox und stöpselst deinen rechner dann in den rj 45 port von
dem access point das dürfte wahrscheinlich die einfachste geschichte dann oder probierst
wirklich mit dlan oder powerline was schreibt nein leute warum sollte man 30 millionen mal
repeaten müssen wenn die fritzbox schon im zweiten stock steht der hat bestimmt guten
wlan empfang in seinem gamingzimmer die fritzbox steht im zweiten stock und sein gaming pc
steht im zweiten stock die sind wahrscheinlich nur zwei dünne räume voneinander weg das
wird wahrscheinlich schon funktionieren so die frage wie man jetzt den krams halt an
rechner dran kriegt also ich würde gucken ob es irgendwelche kabel gibt die ich noch
benutzen kann es muss kein netzwerkabel sein wenn die entfernung nicht so lang ist also
kannst du kannst du kannst mal gucken entweder hast du da irgendwelche telefonkabel noch
rumliegen oder aber irgendwelche unbenutzten kabel fenster auf kabel raus naja naja das
ist auch nicht schön oder irgendwelche unbenutzten kabel wie gesagt es muss nicht unbedingt netzwerkabel
sein wie gesagt man braucht da man braucht doch gar nichts man nimmt einen access point
man nimmt einen 25 euro access point klein modus und stöpselt seinen rechner dran im
zweifelsfall nimmt man sich da noch einen 15 euro switch dabei wenn man mehrere sachen
anschließen will das ist die günstigste variante mit 40 euro dabei und funktioniert wahrscheinlich
genauso gut wie alles andere naja zumindest das ist aber ganz schön wenig das ist aber
ganz schön wenig da scheint er die verbindung nicht so geil zu sein also ich würde gucken
dass ich ob es irgendwelche unbenutzten kabel gibt also was ich bei uns machen werde zum
beispiel also kann ich ich habe ein ähnliches problem das einzige leerrohr was wir haben
ist im im flur zwischen keller und erdgeschoss und ersten stock und deswegen muss ich auch
irgendwie von dort im erdgeschoss oder im zweiten stock noch in meinen serverraum kommen
und was ich mir jetzt überlegt habe ist ich nehme ich nehme alte telefonleitung ich nehme
eine alte telefonleitung zwei adernpaare und mache dann sowas dran fuck ich habe ich habe
vergessen wie das wie das heißt wir haben doch letztens etwas richtig gutes gefunden
ist weiß nicht mehr wie es heißt so was hier
genau irgendwie sowas in der richtung war das das werde ich bei mir probieren zwischen
keller und serverraum einfach weil ich nur eine verbindung brauche netzwerkmäßig und
da leider nichts anderes liegt außer ein paar nicht großartig isolierte kopforkabel
wieso nimmst du die telefonleitung nicht einfach raus weil das weil das durchgängiges kabel
ist ohne großartige durch für hilfe sonst was vom keller in zweiten stock also ich glaube
nicht dass ich da großartig was durchziehen kann also wie gesagt wenn du irgendwelche
unbenutzten kabel hast zwischen den zwei räumen dann hast du eine ganz gute chance da netzwerk
drüber zu kriegen und sei es nur mit irgendwie noch noch noch einen zwischenschritt so gut
mehr fällt mir nicht so ein so einfach ist das nicht da ist kein platz außerdem sind
außerdem sind warum es bei mir auch nicht geht ist außerdem sind zwei adern aus diesem
kabel schon für die telefonen steckdose verwendet also ich kann das kabel gar nicht abmachen
und durchziehen naja gut wie dem auch sei ja hausverkabelung ist so eine sache auf der
arbeit oder im business bereich ist das jetzt nicht so das problem da sagt man halt ok wir
wollen unser z vom keller 5 stok in keller verlegen vom keller 5 stok naja gut wir haben
jetzt einfach mal 3 3 millionen am start und ziehen das um das hat man da halt jetzt mal
nicht so oft ja so und die eigentliche sache wo ich jetzt mal ganz ursprünglich drauf
raus wollte ist mein kühlschrank ist kaputt der hat wahrscheinlich irgendwann heute nacht
also zum glück ist nicht der einzige kühlschrank also f das ist zum glück nicht der einzige
kühlschrank also ich habe bei mir hinten in der in der mini küche einstehen und wir
haben auch unten in der küche noch einstehen also da geht jetzt nichts großartiges kaputt
aber ich brauche einen zweiten kühlschrank und ich habe absolut keinen blassen schimmer
gekauft irgendwas kleines billiges was ich viel stromverbrauch kennt sich da irgendjemand
von euch mit aus ich denke mal nicht oder ist der kühlschrank pro von euch exzellent
kühlschrank expert hauptsache mehr als ein kühlschrank mit zwei stok werden zwei leuten
bosch siemens a plus plus plus plus smart fridge ne das hole ich mir nicht smart smarter
kühlschrank ist komplett sinnlos ich habe gestern wieder gesehen hier auf twitter internet
auf shit shit also ein bild gesehen ja lizenzbedingungen auf einem backofen so weit sind wir schon
lizenzbedingungen eine tolle tolle schuhe hier am start äh lizenzbedingungen auf einem
fucking backofen so weit ist es wahrscheinlich auf der mischung aus herd und backofen sowas
beknackt ist oder will ich zum beispiel ok von was ok heißt das von mediamarkt ich bestell
mir sowas bei amazon das hat den vorteil da kommt auch der wird auch gleich geliefert
bei amazon kostet glaube ich irgendwie 20 euro extra und warum ist das jetzt auf einmal
so teuer so weil smarter kühlschrank ist was kostet bei amazon glaube ich 20 euro extra
und die tragen die sogar den ersten stock und stellen den auf aber es hat es hat sich
schon abgezeichnet dass der kaputt ging dass der kaputt geht der kühlschrank weil da hat
die letzten tage schon übelst gestunken wahrscheinlich irgendwas ausgelaufen oder so von irgendwie
von irgendeinem kühlmittel oder sonst was da ist ja nahezu nichts drin also es kann
nicht sein was innen drin war was da gestunken hat da hat die letzten tage übelst gestunken
und jetzt macht er halt jetzt kühlt er halt nicht mehr sehr gut jetzt habe ich ihn ausgemacht
und was ist das hier was das da ok was ist das wow das ist ein riesen ding ich meinte
was kleines ich meinte nix wo man irgendwie darknet organe drin lagern kann oder sowas
so eine ganz ganz normalen kleinen kühlschrank gefrierfach wäre nicht verkehrt ja
begehbarer kühlschrank ok wie nennt sich das ganze denn hier kühlzelle wiesmann classic
edition what the fuck classic edition kälte berlin das könnte das könnte irgend so ein
möchte gern hip hop typ sein oder oder irgendein hip hop label kälte berlin wiesmann kühlschrank
ein schnapper das ist ja fast geschenkt nur nur 2700 euro und man kann das ganze per vorkasse
bezahlen na wenn das nicht verlocken das chris stonehenge ehrlich gesagt wäre mir sogar
lieber wenn wenn das nicht so groß wäre am liebsten hätte ich sowas ganz kleines kurz
kleines so so irgendwie eins oder zwei schupplern tiefkühler und dann irgendwie eins oder zwei
einschübe für rest reicht das ist ja nur der zweite kühlschrank hier bei mir im im
ersten stock die eigentliche sache ist ja im erdgeschoss in dem großen drin aber das
ist vielleicht ein bisschen teuer und nicht klein du kannst da kannst du deinen rack
reinstellen ja das stimmt da kann ich mein rack reinstellen und ich bin übrigens geradebei
überlegen ob ich ein größeres rack kaufen soll allerdings ist es schwierig den grosses
nenen sagen wir mal so denn keine ahnung 30 he oder sowas ganz hohes will ich nicht nur
ein bisschen höher ich habe ja aktuell ist meins glaube ich wie hoch ist mein rack eigentlich
12 he 14 he was ist denn das leute wie viel he könnten das sein lasst mal gucken 1 2 gibt
es gibt es auch in scharf gibt es das auch in scharf max so jetzt hier also wie viel
oder hier mal ja 1 2 3 4 warte mal 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 11 he unten ist ja noch eins
frei 11 he oder so also so 20 werden dann schon nicht verkehrt weil mittlerweile ist
es halt ziemlich vollgestopft und ich fände es halt auch ganz cool wenn ich nicht noch
einen zweiten schrank bräuchte da würde ich mir nämlich oben einfach 3 4 einschübe
rein machen und dann lässt sich so ein rack wunderbar auch als schrank verwenden das problem
ist nur das rack ist glaube ich nur 40 cm tief und da gibt es nicht so viele da gibt
es wirklich ja genau 19 zoll rack small da gibt es wirklich nicht viele die hier sind
halt ultra teuer 12 he 12 12 ist das ungefähr was ich auch habe weil die sache ist halt
die mein raum ist nicht sonderlich groß ihr seht ja hier im video das ist das ist ja schon
alles hier ihr seht ja ich stehe hier in der tür das ist alles dafür ist der raum ziemlich
hoch also die räume hier sind höher als normale normale ich weiß ich weiß nicht wie hoch
normale räume sind aber die räume hier sind ein ticken höher als normale räume das merke
ich auch immer wenn ich in anderen wohnungen bin so und es ist halt ein bisschen bisschen
ein bisschen voll wenn das ganze doppelt so hoch wäre ich so viel ablage und storage
möglichkeiten noch dass ich das richtig lohnen wird aber es gibt nichts gescheites es gibt
kaum server racks oder 19 zoll racks die halt nicht so tief sind es gibt so kleine netzwerkschränke
so was aber da passt die kiste nicht rein ist schwierig da was gescheites zu finden
irgendwie rack moundsmart also das ist eine seite von 1995 ich gehe weg und um nicht zu
sagen übrigens sehr guter twitter kanal kann ich kann ich nur empfehlen internet auf schitts
ja das ist so unglaublich unsinnig die ganzen smart kühlschränke eine kühlschrank wird
doch nicht smart dadurch dass der vorne ein tablet drauf hat ich erwarte von einem smarten
kühlschrank dass er seine aufgabe nämlich kühlschrank zu sein besser macht ich brauche
da vorne kein touch screen mit android kalender hast du nicht gesehen drauf das ist vielleicht
so ein nicer zusatz aber ganz ehrlich da kann ich einfach nen tablet nehmen und an
den kühlschrank kleben das ist genauso gut das braucht man dafür nicht ich frage mich
warum die das nicht hinkriegen klassische haushaltsgeräte mal ordentlich smart zu machen
das erste was mir einfallen würde beispielsweise bei einem kühlschrank genau ich weiß dass
man hier was was hier pizze luste schreibt ich weiß dass man sich eine kamera angucken
kann aber ich finde eine kamera im kühlschrank die man sich dann auf dem smartphone angucken
kann ist eigentlich der falsche der falsche wegen kühlschrank smart zu machen ja was
die dinger was die dinger machen müssten meiner meinung nach um das mal fortnite ist
der grund du meinst dir für das tablet dass das wäre nen das wäre nen mittel für für
nen eine millionen klick youtube video irgendwie fortnite easy fortnite win auf kühlschrank
das wird instant eine million klicks eine million aufrufe wird wird sofort wird sofort
funktionieren dass sowas geht immer so also zumindest was ich sagen wollte um eigentlich
einen kühlschrank richtig smart zu machen was ich da erwarten würde und was irgendwie
die hersteller aber nicht richtig machen vor allem auch die japaner nicht japaner die koreaner
in dem fall hier nicht ist was mir kann man sagen was mir so vorschwebt inwieweit man
das jetzt großartig realisieren kann weiß ich nicht aber ich glaube es ist nicht soweit
nicht soweit nicht nicht soweit vom von der realität entfernt als erstes zum beispiel
gerade geschrieben hat barcode scanner das schon mal nicht verkehrt wobei ich ganz ehrlich
sogar noch einen schritt weitergehen würde erstens erkennung ai stützt was auch immer
bildmäßig erkennung was drinne ist man kann den kühlschrank ja noch ein bisschen unterstützen
indem man das ding kategorisiert wo man in der regel was hinstellt also erstmal erkennung
was ist drinne da gibt es ja zig varianten was man machen kann man kann gucken entweder
die oldschool variante vielleicht mit irgendwelchen id chips das wäre ein bisschen unpraktisch
mit mit barcode lesern mit generell erkennen was das ist guck mal mittlerweile sind wir
so weit dass ein algorithmus dir sagen kann was auf einem bild zu sehen ist und damit
relativ gut liegt meistens ja manchmal kommt auch totaler schwachsinn raus ja also wir sind
heute so weit dass du ein bild hochladen kannst und das ding spuckt dir aus alte frau beim
gassi gehen so nach dem motto das also da sind wir richtig gut da kann mir doch keiner
erzählen wenn man das erkennen kann dass in den kühlschrank nicht erkennen kann ob da
eine milchtüte steht oder irgendwie eine packung pommes frites also das würde ich erwarten
dass in die richtung geht dass das ding erst mal erkennt was ist drinne dann dass das ding
eine prognose abgibt quasi dem und dem verbrauch heißt das das und das müsste man demnächst
wieder einkaufen gehen dass das ding mir sagt ok ich weiß morgens wird immer das und das
rausgenommen und wenn du das jetzt fünf tagen so machst nächste woche ist es all solche
geschichten das werden so sachen die würden das die würden das leben dann wirklich einfacher
machen mit dem kühlschrank der der smart ist und die könnte man auch wirklich smart
auf fack was ist das denn das könnte man auch wirklich smart nennen auf fack das video
ist zugegangen was warum ich wusste dass das funktioniert das ganze mal ich wusste
dass es funktioniert es leckt ein bisschen an der chrome kaste das oder ne oder was macht
was macht er da eigentlich fack man du kannst fortal echt auf dem kühlschrank spielen
unglaublich sinnlos so das nächste ist sowas wie serious max schreibt wieviel views hat
das video nicht so viele wie ich gedacht hätte nur 30.000 ich hätte eigentlich gedacht der
hätte das clickbait mehr clickbait nennen müssen irgendwie irgendwie you don't guess
what happens next playing on smart fridge da gibt's ich bin ich gut im clickbait titel
ausdenken ich kann so ich kann sie dir an meinen videos ja also nicht vorhanden aktuell
nicht vorhanden videos ich bin ich gut drin mir clickbait playing on fortnight pro gamer
hassen diesen trick irgendwie sowas noch hinten dran ist das eigentlich hingekommen
ich wollte noch mal zum kühlschrank so dann könnte das ding beispielsweise wie das hier
des marks gesagt hat sogar die temperatur automatisch einstellen es gibt so mehr viele
sinnvolle sachen was man an kühlschrank machen könnte dass er smart ist im endeffekt anstatt
da einfach eine kamera rein zu klatschen ich was ich bei der heim automatisierung ja auch
immer sach ist wir reden ja von automatisierung also sprich von arbeit abnehmen oder sachen
erkennen und sachen automatisch machen die ich normalerweise per hand machen würde also
sprich das gibt so drei schritte so das wenn man sich jetzt mal ein lichtschalter anguckt
zum beispiel so er basic schritt ist man hat erstmal ein lichtschalter man kann licht
an und aus machen nächster step ist man hat ein lichtschalter den man auch remote schalten
kann dann muss ich aber immer noch schalten ich habe aber den vorteil dass wenn ich schon
auf dem sofa sitz ich immer noch das licht in der küche ausschalten kann weil ich vergessen
habe oder so aber der eigentliche gewinn was heim automatisierung anbelangt ist ja dann
wenn das licht zur richtigen zeit im richtigen raum angeht ohne dass ich auf den schalter
drücken muss und das ist ja mit dem kühlschrank edel einfach nur eine kamera rein hängen und
fette touchscreen davor machen macht das ding nicht smart auch wenn es viele gute bewertung
hat was mich eigentlich gesagt wundert bei so einem krab wobei ich mich frage wie machen
die das eigentlich mit android updates auf dem kühlschrank ich meine da ist ja ist ja
eindeutig da muss ja android drauf sein wie machen die das damit android updates mein
android update policy kennen wir ja die kommt wahrscheinlich die neue android version kann
man beliebige apps runter da und hat nur die start apps dann ist es wahrscheinlich gar
kein android sondern es ist wahrscheinlich sam wie heißt das tützen oder samsung tützen
tizen ich weiß nicht wie man das ausspricht tützen das ist ja der name nein das heißt
bestimmt tizen aber nicht aber nicht tützen eget java script java script auf dem kühlschrank
ja 2020
besser ganz genau hinschauen ja gut kostet aber unter dem strich ja nicht
der kühlschrank keine no frost technik das hat sogar unser uralt kühlschrank unten er
hat keine antibakter moment kühlschränke haben antibakterielle technik wie sieht denn
eine antibakterielle technik im kühlschrank aus wird dann eben wird ein irgendwelches giftgas
hinzugemischt oder was das das bakterien ne das kann nicht sein wie soll das funktionieren
uv licht beschichtung von den platten ich habe keine ahnung das lese ich zum ersten
mal das kühlschränke was antibakterielles haben weil die meisten sind auch in tüten
drinne egal er hat keine klimazone sogar das hat unser uralt kühlschrank das ist es ist
einmal außer dass ein fettes touch screen vorne dran gemacht haben ist da nix nix halbes
und nix ganzes das ding er hat keinen wasser spend moment das hat unsere auch nicht er
hat keine türfunktion wie kriegt man ihn dann auf wenn er keine türfunktion hat das
ist fake das tibet da geht gar nicht auf der kühlt ohne dass man es rein stellen kann
wahrscheinlich meinte irgendwas spezielles so nach dem motto es geht licht an oder so
keine ahnung das haben der kühlschrank von meiner oma schon gemacht das licht angeht
wenn die tür aufgeht es läuft ja kein end und es läuft tützen sag ich doch genau kameras
bringt halt überhaupt nix all die musik einfach gerade das ist also ich ziemlich erschwach
sene beautiful fridge schön breit naja gut was auch immer so ein schwachsinn also das
sowas kaufe ich mir nicht ihr wisst ich bin technik fern auch smart home fern allerdings
nicht mit sowas sinnlosen das richtig lost ja wer sich so n müll kauft schau dir mal
sowas an es ist viel zu teuer ich will irgendwas kleines also es gibt aber es gibt überhaupt
kein sinn dass ich mir so was teueres kaum ich brauche es ich bin es richtig kleines
keine ahnung irgendwas was mir bis bis zum arsch geht von der höhe her es muss gar
nicht so groß sein falls sowas überhaupt gibt wie gesagt der hauptsächlich die kühlschrank
ist hier unten ja sowas hier sowas klingt das sieht doch schon mal ganz gut aus kristin
hensch sowas sieht doch mal ganz gut aus das macht jetzt auch nicht aus sowas hier man
macht mal kurz den da krieg doch aus so ein kleines futzding genau das ist wunderbar
für mich was ist denn da alles drin abtaufvorgang was kann der ja das ist sowas genau sowas
er kann kühlen led beleuchtung immerhin schon ich hoffe ja rgb ein cooler kühlschrank das
pains champ das tut weh genau sowas sowas brauche ich 215 euro das bin ich auch bereit
dafür auszugeben im prinzip ganz kleines furzding richtig reicht dick für mich gonna box für
obst die bei mir natürlich immer komplett voll ist wie ihr euch ja alle denken könnt
zwei einschübe und gefrierfach optimal sowas brauche ich genau sowas kristin hensch du
hast genau erkannt nicht hier irgendwelche anderen geschichten für 2500 euro optimal
es gibt kaum ordentlich ausweichen wahrscheinlich weil alle mittlerweile denken sie sind viel
geiler wenn sie alle geräte in ultra groß haben ich mein ihr wisst mir geht es dann
weniger um die kohle sondern eher um das was sinnvoll ist und ihr wisst ja auch ich hab
so richtig kleine scheiß auto aber ich fahre halt kein auto warum soll ich mir was großes
fettes kaufen bloß um da irgendwie auf dicke hose machen zu können ich müsste eh nicht
was ich damit machen soll außer irgendwo posen vielleicht da bin ich nicht der richtige
für so lass es liefern ja mache ich auch guck mal was es bei amazon kostet gibt's
nicht muss den über amazon weil weil amazon hat einen richtig coolen service was kühlschrank
angeht oder schwere geräte das kostet 20 euro mehr hier liefern es dir ins haus an
die stelle wo es aufgestellt wird asbach uhr alles mir doch egal das geht beckow was
ist beckow das sieht aus wie der kühlschrank von meiner oma so richtig old school also richtig
old school aber das reicht beckow das ist nur a plus umweltanzeige ist raus muss ich
mal gucken wie ich das mache a plus plus plus plus plus und das erinnert mich an die komische
escher schulung die ich letzte woche gemacht habe der trainer der hat immer alle alle keine
ahnung eine stunde gesagt so wir machen kurz pause und der wollt dann immer dass man doppelt
plus schreibt immer doppelt plus wer schon wieder da ist und irgendwie hat mich das
ein bisschen an 1984 erinnert und an 10 plus plus doppelt plus wir sind doppelt plus anwesend
der chat ist der chat ist auch doppelt plus anwesend aber alles in allem muss man sagen
die schulung war nicht und das ist auch geil das habe ich gestern auch schon gesehen das
video das ist halt so typisch das ist halt wohl typisch norwegen das hat übrigens keinen
sound das ist so typisch so typisch norwegen elch ist es glaube ich ein elch und ein rasenmeer
der robotter der rasenmeer robotter stellt sich an den elch ran und der elch denkt sich
einfach jetzt nur das ding ist kaputt rekt jetzt könnte ich mir ein paar mal den loop
angucken und bäem ich mein der typ der fahrt der hat sich bestimmt nicht gefreut darüber
dass es nicht ganz im arsch ist wollte ich euch auch noch erzählen ich bin letztens durch
eine siedlung hier gelaufen das sind hauptsächlich so ein familienhäuser also das sind so neubau
siedlungen wo viele familien mit kinder wohnen und so weil es nicht so teuer ist laufe ich
letztens durch zum aldi und also muss man durch zwei siedlungen durch dann bis man beim aldi
kann man ohne probleme hin laufen so korona korona zweite welle monkaes zu mindestens bevor
ich das bin ich durch die siedlung gelaufen und auf einmal sehe ich auf der straße einen
staubsauger robotter den rasenmeer da hat irgend einer sein ding nicht richtig abgesteckt
die dinger erkennen ja also die billig dinge erkennen ja anhand einem kabel oder einem
draht oder sonst was was man um sein kunststück drumherum macht dass sie im im im rahmen sind
also im garten das hat er wohl irgendwie nicht richtung nicht richtig gemacht da ist einfach
so ein ding auf der straße rumgefahren ich hätte eigentlich fotografieren müssen ich
habe doch hochfassen das seit nicht auf der straße halt auf der auf der straße in der
siedlung da fährt ja nichts aber es hat mich schon überrascht dass auf einmal in den rasenmeer
robotter an mir vorbei so schräg vorbeigedüst ist nature finds the way der hat ihn bestimmt
gesucht wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich hat er sich danach noch beim nachbar beschwert dass
der nachbar ihm den geklaut hat oder so so hier was ist hier los zweite welle oh jetzt
drin sind infektionszahlen steigen nicht testzahlen steigen zweite welt aber die leute kommen jetzt aus
im urlaub wieder da kein wunder jetzt ich kann mir twitter nicht mehr geben ich halte das nicht
aus twitter ist twitter ist komplett cancer mittlerweile ich habe auf andorra umgestellt
mein twitter und seitdem lebe ich viel entspannter ich muss mir nichts mehr angucken ja keine
empörten leute aus welcher richtung auch immer einfach wird er auf andorra umstellen und ruhe
ist ich wollte sagen kommt mir doch bekannt vor ja es gibt irgendwelche leute die mongo datenbanken
löschen das aber auch so was wo ich mir denke das hast du also hast fast dir kann es eigentlich
gar nicht besser passieren als wenn die datenbank die du öffentlich im internet zugreifbar hast
wenn dort die leute nur die daten überschreiben und miau reinschreiben die kann eigentlich fast
nichts besseres passieren im schlimmsten fall nisten die sich irgendwo ein und du kriegst
gar nicht mit also eigentlich eigentlich ist das beste was dir passieren kann dann weißt du deine
datenbank war nicht gesichert oder du hast irgendeine angreifbare version ich habe übrigens letztens
gesehen auf der arbeit wir haben noch mongo db3 was war vor 34 30 irgendwas 304 302 oder so 307 was
die letzte 30er serie die genau das das haben wir noch das haben wir noch am start ich habe
letztens auf irgendeinem uralt server am arsch der welt bei mir auf der arbeit gefunden wir haben
noch mongo db30 das ding du kriegst die pakete dafür nicht mal mehr das ist richtig all school
das ist die neue bahn app das ist gut die bahn die bahn hat übrigens wieder eine neue app
weiß auch nicht was mit der bahn los ist warum die laufen neue apps brauchen der next db navigator
kommt jetzt nämlich hier das ist so lächerlich wenn man nämlich mal im play store guckt und
sucht nach nach bahn kann man überhaupt suchen drinnen deutsche bahn warum hat die bahn nix
anderes zu tun was ist mit denen eigentlich verkehrt haben die zu viel geld jetzt mal ohne
scheiß haben die zu viel ok das meiste ist nicht von der bahn ja aber also das hier unten ist
alles nicht von der bahn aber das ist von der bahn das ist von der bahn das ist also im prinzip
alles wo deutsche bahn dran steht ist von der bahn warum was was ist mit denen los also ihr
seht hier unten dass das da unten ist alles nicht von der bahn aber das hier also quasi bis hier
so und das schlimme ist ja dass sie auch noch so viele apps haben die die doppeldeutsche zum
beispiel der navigator und der strecken agent ist mehr oder weniger genau das gleiche nur dass
der strecken agent eigentlich die bessere app ist mit dem unterschied dass der strecken agent
keine tickets unterstützt tickets kann nur der navigator also strecken agent ist für reines
navigieren und verspätung anzeigen und so was eigentlich viel besser aber der strecken agent
kann keine tickets für tickets brauchte navigator bahn warum das fackt mich richtig ab der scheiß
so und jetzt haben die wieder was neues jetzt kommt der nächste db navigator
egal ich verstehe ich verstehe den sinn davon ich zumindest haben es geschafft
bisschen geld flingster was so geil ist flingster car sharing so was könnte man wunderbar alles
hier einbauen wissen wir müsste einfach db ausflug wer braucht den scheiß ausflüge mit der bahn
den ganzen kram könnte man ohne probleme alles in eine app einbauen wenn man das ding
gescheit strukturieren würde so dass man die leute halt nicht unnötig vollkleistert mit db
ausflug wenn die einfach nur ein ticket kaufen wollen unfähig das ist wahnsinn ich glaube das
ist eine komplett neue app ich habe letztens behaise bahn app behaise gelesen dass die dass
das eine neue app ist vielleicht ist das vielleicht an den anderen ersetzt aber aktuell ist es eine
neue app so kann man kann man im ios app store eigentlich online suchen geht das das wäre so
typisch apple style wenn das geht die bahn ok kann man nicht alles aber ich meine auch
schon hier was warum db navigator db bahnhof live strecken agent die beste sache für verspätung
ist eh da kann ich mir nie die webseite merken nämlich marauder ne maruda ah wie heißt die
bei ich hab die in den bookmarks kann man nicht merken wie man das schreibt bahn seite
ma gu da was bahn guru ne das ist was anderes oder heißt es jetzt bahn guru ne ne ne da gab's
wie heißt das denn die ist richtig nice weil die sich live updated das heißt irgendwas
urada oder auch gottbahn marudor ja genau betf so kann man nämlich hier bahnhof frankfurt machen
und man kriegt das richtig schön auf die minute genau angezeigt und richtig und und mit mit schnellen
updates alles das die beste seite wenn man wirklich einen überblick haben will was gerade abgeht
wofür das auch echt praktisch ist wenn man einfach nur wissen will wie sieht es aktuell am bahnhof
aus zum beispiel wenn frankfurt süd guck mal was frankfurt süd aussieht wenn man jetzt sagt ok
ich laufe jetzt gleich los es ist immer gut zu gucken einfach mal auf den bahnhof selbst wenn
hier nämlich alles alles rot ist und nur dein zug ist grün da stimmt meistens irgendwas nicht
gibt es noch diese app wo man die züge bei gps treten kann das ging doch in der navigator app
und das ding hier ist genauer als die bahn app also das ist richtig gut hier excellent was der
macht ist nämlich da gibt es auch einen vortrag von ihm was der macht ist der holt sich die
daten nicht nur von der bahn die ja das ist richtig da gibt es übrigens einen vortrag dazu
gucken wir uns jetzt nicht an der hier bahn app chaos was der macht ist ich glaube das ist der
mit dieser seite ich bin mir jetzt nicht ganz sicher in dem zusammenhängen was der macht ist der
fragt nicht bei der bahn die offizielle bahn api ab sondern der nimmt von allen verkehrsverbünden
die informationen und ja kombiniert die miteinander das heißt das ist genauer als
die offizielle bahn app und es kann nämlich auch durchaus sein dass keine ahnung beim rmv
steht der zug als verspätung da aber in bayern steht der zug pünktlich da so und deswegen wenn
das wenn der zug nämlich beim rmv verspätung hat aber in der bayern app nicht oder in der
offiziellen bahn app für bayern dann beim bayern nicht dann weiß der dass der zug höchstwahrscheinlich
trotzdem verspätung hat weil er ist zwar grad noch in hessen aber wenn er 15 minuten verspätung hat
ist er nicht drei haltestellen später in bayern dann pünktlich also die seite ist wirklich super
kann man nur empfehlen und wofür ich die immer benutzen wenn ich los gehe bevor ich los gehe auf
der arbeit mittags mache ich immer einmal die seite auch für frankfurts süd die bahn möchte
verspätung nicht nicht anzeigen habe ich manchmal das gefühl das wirkt dann zu zu verspätet einfach
ich mache die seite einfach immer bevor ich los laufe auf der arbeit mal kurz noch mal auf und
guckt drauf wie sieht es allgemein an frankfurts süd aus aktuell sieht es ganz ok aus aber es
gibt tage da gehst du hier drauf wobei hier das auch schon wieder geht aber noch da gehst du
hier drauf und frankfurts süd ist für die nächste stunde irgendwie rot und allerdings der moment
lauter bahnapp ist mein zug pünktlich der müsste aber jetzt erst noch am hauptbahnhof losfahren
aber wenn in süd alles rot ist ist die wahrscheinlichkeit dass man zug nicht pünktlich
ist deutlich höher vielleicht gehe ich doch zum hauptbahnhof und so was also kann man nur
empfehlen top top webseite und ich habe übrigens schon wieder vergessen diese würde es mal rauder
oder so heißen dann wird mich das an die oder mir oder wird mich dann an die starcraft einheit
erinnern ja aber die diese seite ich kann sie mir einfach nicht merken wenn ich die nicht
gebucht markt hätte wer ja also exzellent wie mir hier schon sieht ist in frankfurt das übliche es
ist eigentlich so gut wie nix wirklich pünktlich aber am hauptbahnhof geht halt auch die post ab
warten auf freie fahrt verspätet sonstige qualitätsmenge zugverkehrt moment
zugverkehrt richtig gereiht ist es jetzt ist es jetzt gut oder schlecht ist es nur gut oder
schlecht für die zu richtig oder verkehrt oder ist er gut ärztliche versorgung eines fahrgastes
ja und er hat halt einfach mehr informationen als die bahn weil er das von allen verkehrsverbunden
nimmt so zum beispiel der fährt oder moment der zug der kommt oder fährt nach hanau der fährt
nach der kommt der fährt nach frankfurt der fährt nach hamburg fährt nach hamburg und
der kommt kommt aus der schweiz und die wissen schon die diesen aus sind die ausgehalten ausgefallen
oder was sagt einem das hier naja was auch immer aber das ist wirklich super seite
so kühlschrank
wie gehört irgendwelche weep dinger
ja so ja leute wie gesagt ich habe auch gar nichts großartig vor ich hatte bloß ein
schlechtes gewissen dass wenn ich jetzt den halben tag pass of exile kreisel kreinde und
gar kein stream anmache obwohl ich am freitag oder am donnerstag gesagt habe ich mache
am samstag mal den stream an ich habe mich da irgendwie dem chat in gewisser art und
weise verpflichtet gefühlt heute aber eine runde stream zu machen
thank you für treffling ja also wenn ihr wollt ich weiß dass es nicht viele interessiert
aber ein paar scheint es zu interessieren also ich kann ruhig mal neuen mal neuen pass
of exile character hier im stream leveln aber vorher muss ich noch was essen
was war es der der ist in basel gestartet da die schweiz keinen bock auf die verschwindung
da dürfen die jetzt echt echt jetzt das wäre richtig poggers genauso muss das machen das
ist das ist also wenn das stimmt besser könntest du gar nicht zur deutschen bahn sagen
in die schweiz ziehen haben halt keinen bock auf den scheiß was die bahn fabrizieren kann
ich verstehen was was trendet eigentlich gerade auf geht hat mal schnell reingucken leute wir
gucken uns jetzt noch ein barbeque pit boys video an das haben wir hier lollipop chicken
excellent hell yeah kokona time wir gucken uns auch ein barbeque pit boy video an und
ich esse schnell was dann mal eine runde pass of exile stream so weiter aber erstmal ja
welcome to the barbeque pit boys dot com and today we cooking some chicken on the grill
today we're grilling up some lollipop chicken at the pit and okay fast fast ich muss ihr
müsst zugeben ich war recht nah dran spg seasoning die machete wieder jawoll diesmal
diesmal ist das ist hier das messer sieht schon oder diese zwischen den zwischen messer
und machete das sieht schon hart mitgenommen aus will ich wissen wie viele kühe sie damit
schon selbst geschlachtet haben wir so why is it called lollipop chicken well it looks
like a lollipop when you're finished grilling so this is how you do it you take your old
hickory right and you take the chicken leg and you cut around it and what you're doing
is cutting off the tendons they're going up and down this leg this allows you to slide
the meat up the bone right just like that and then you're able to take the chicken skin
right and pull it on over just like that now ja wie lange will er das jetzt noch machen
jetzt wirklich fünf minuten zugucken wie er an dem hähnchenschenkel rummacht hier gehts
los jetzt wirds gesiesent eigentlich ist das richtig nice ich glaube das muss ich auch
mal machen guck mal hähnchen keule hast ja dann normalerweise hier komplett das das fleisch
alles und hier hast du quasi so ein stick wo du gut angreifen kannst und du hast mehr
fleisch auf einmal eigentlich ist das richtig big brain da können nur die amis wieder drauf
kommen whatever you got freedom chicken we're using a kettle grill today we're gonna do
indirect grilling we've got the charcoal placed in the middle of the grill with this particular
grill unit right and we're gonna place the lollipop chickens right around the edge again
not directly over the flames because that's just burnt we want to bake it like we're doing
in an oven and yes before you ask you could do these in your oven at home but who would
want to do that das muss richtig schön schwarz sein richtig schön verkohlt aus dann alright
the lollipop chickens have been placed the temperature is about 350 degrees fahrenheit
more or less and it won't take long to do alright take a look at this we're probably a half
hour into this but use your chef instant read thermometer to get the exit jetzt wo ich das sehe da
fällt mir eine sache ein als ich noch bei dem als ich noch beim provider gearbeitet habe ich
erzähle ich habe früher mal bei einem provider gearbeitet da hatten wir eine weihnachtsfeier
und extra von frankfurt runtergefahren dahin für die weihnachtsfeier so und wir haben übelst
hunger und normalerweise gab es auf der weihnachtsfeier auch immer extrem viel zu fressen also richtig
viel man kann sich anders bezeichnen als als extrem viel zu fressen nein easy killer das
war nicht das weihnachtsgrill aber das weihnachtsgrill war aber auch auf der weihnachtsfeier von der
firma ja also es gab wirklich massig zu futtern so und wir sind halt runtergefahren haben uns
gedacht okay gleich gibt es wieder richtig essen und auf einmal fangen die an verteilen halt so
so finger food appetizer da hast du dann so einen löffel gekriegt mit ein paar bohnen drauf oder
halt auch mal so einen deswegen bin ich habe ich da gerade dran gedacht oder halt auch mal so
einen hähnchen stick oder irgendwelche anderen so finger food dinger es gab dann sachen in so einer
eistüte drin und so was das hat gut geschmeckt muss man sagen und das ging dann so eine halbe
stunde und gegen so eine stunde gegen so eineinhalb stunden und irgendwann war vorbei und wir haben
uns alle so gedacht so langsam aber sicher könnte auch mal das essen kommen jetzt und es kam nichts
diese finger food geschichte war halt so das einzige was den ganzen abend über verteilt wurde
das war wahrscheinlich ultra teuer aber es war mega jebait es war ultra jebait es hatten alle
noch brutal hunger und das was dazu geführt hat ist dass die leute um 22 uhr auf der weihnachtsfeier
so extrem besoffen war ich nicht aber die meisten so extrem besoffen waren weil sie nichts vorher
gefordert haben dass sie quasi schon durch halb ulm gerollt sind mehr oder weniger das sind auch
wieder dinger passiert auf der weihnachtsfeier das lässt eigentlich keinem erzählen da hatten
sie eine aus dem support und irgendein anderer typ auf der weihnachtsfeier keine namen ist
auch vollkommen egal ging es dann so weit dass sie die waren beide keine ahnung damals irgendwie
30 oder so älter als ich damals auf jeden fall und das ging dann so weit dass die eltern von ihr
wohlgemerkt die war 30 die polizei angerufen haben weil die tochter nach der weihnachtsfeier
nicht heim gekommen ist so und dann ist die polizei los hat sich nachher rausgestellt die
ist halt mit einem von der weihnachtsfeier heimgegangen das war dann riesen drama und
geduld das wieder ein weiterer grund für warum ich zwischenmenschliche sachen prinzipiell nicht
mag und schon auf der weihnachtsfeier bei der firma schon mal gar nicht ja und was ich gemacht
habe auf der weihnachtsfeier dann eigentlich mit mir da hätte ich das anders erzählt da und was
ich nach der weihnachtsfeier auf der firma gemacht habe ist ich bin erst mal um die ecke
zum subway gegangen ja subway die einzige stelle in ulm die ich kenne und die ich mich gut erinnere
an die ich mich gerne zurück erinnere ist das subway wahrscheinlich wohnt elotrix auch irgendwo
keine ahnung ist das subway in ulm und zwar der wo auch das münster ist das einzige stelle wo
ich mich wirklich gerne daran erinnere an ulm da dieser subway exzellent da bin ich nämlich immer
nach der weihnachtsfeier war nicht die einzige weihnachtsfeier wo ich da gewesen bin bin ich
nach der weihnachtsfeier nämlich immerhin und habe noch ein subway sandwich gefuddert
gibt es ja auch satteliten satteliten bilder noch der ulm ist eine absolute kackstart ich
mag ulm ja ich bin auch vorbelastet ja ich konnte mir nicht auf satteliten modus umschalten
wo konnte man auf satteliten ansicht glaube ich habe einfach ich bin so weit reingezoomt
er konnte doch hier warum kann man da nicht auf satteliten
kann man deswegen kann man das wenigstens öffnen in google maps jetzt von hier
directions ah jetzt ja und monka ist was jetzt los da jetzt kann man hier umschalten auf oder
auch nicht ich bin zu dumm für google maps guckt mal an er hier sattelite das ist das
abweichen nee ja aber da irgendwo genau da hinten ist die nervigste kirche der welt
ich hatte nämlich mal ein hotel hier ist das münster das ist so dass das das aushängeschild
von ulm irgendwo game ab fünf monat dankeschön excellent subscription big brain chat heute
wieder dankeschön für den sub ich hatte hier irgendwo mal ein hotel irgendwo hier hinten
hier so was ist das und dieser diese kirche die klingelt nachts die sind nicht in der lage
diese scheißglocke auszuschalten du bist nachts im hotel und das ding bimmelt einmal die stunde
du drehst durch du kannst überhaupt nicht schlafen irgendwo hier hinten war das hotel
irgendwo hier drinnen ich weiß nicht hotel ich muss mal kurz gucken was das hotel für
wertung hat maps google wir sehen münster hotel auch noch münster hotel ulm nein das
war das garantiert nicht oder sattelite doch das könnte das tatsächlich gewesen sein hat
viel zu gute bewertung das ist mega trash gewesen das hotel das kann es nicht sein das
ist zu teuer das hat 15 euro die nacht gekostet das war ich noch aber ein paar bilder
ne im leben war das also das ist das essen und ach keine ahnung scheiß drauf ich will
eigentlich gar nicht ich musste eigentlich gar nicht dran erinnert werden ehrlich gesagt
ist das legal ruhe störungen so das ist kultur das juckt die nicht ob das ruhe störungen
ist oder nicht näh näh zumindest haben sie mich da einquartiert hier wir machen das
jetzt eigentlich zu haben sie mich einquartiert im komischen hotel da und das war das billigste
das billigste hotel ever das hatte 15 und 20 euro die nacht gekostet und das war das
billig oder 25 mega billig und das war das billigste das billigste zimmer was die hatten
mit eigenem klo der also die hatten auch noch zimmer mit gemeinschafts klo so das war das
billigste das war das billigste mit klo so und das was sie da drunter verstanden haben
war aber es war eine klo schüssel mitten im zimmer also das war das war wahrscheinlich
gerade noch nicht fertig der raum und sie haben schon vermietet oder so also sprich es
war eine klo schüssel es war unten gekachelt auf der erde da stand eine klo schüssel drauf
daneben stand eine dusche und daneben stand ein bett da war keine wand drumherum
das war das schrecklichste hotel kann ich mich nicht mehr dran erinnern
nein im leben ist das nicht im leben ist es das nicht aber das ziemlich sicher na gut
ja mittlerweile ziemlich sicher hieß das hotel münster vielleicht gibt es das auch gar nicht
mehr na doch da ging sie irgendwo rein dann doch das war das glaube ich ja genau so ähnlich
waren die zimmer da so guck mal hier ist das waschbecken auch mitten im zimmer so bei mir
war halt noch das klo mitten im zimmer so richtig kleines kackdinger aber es ist mittlerweile
besser es ist mittlerweile besser ansonsten kann ich da nichts schlechtes drüber sagen
ich mein 15 oder 20 euro die nacht ist ja nur wirklich der witz gewesen ja was kostet
was kostet das günstigste hier zeigt mal das ist das hier zimmer wie viel kostet das
heute so ich weiß ich bin ein bisschen side tracked gerade hallo
so treiber zimmer und budget hallo na fuck die seite ist broken gut ist egal ich wollte
ich wollte es nur mal zum besten geben ja also das war andere zeit noch habe ich eigentlich
irgendwelche fragen übersehen da hier dazu trainen
irgendjemand hat gerade gefragt habe ich hier gekonnt gekonnt überlesen glaube ich gerade
die frage der fragen die hier immer kommt gute tips um in programmieren einzusteigen
ja habe ich bist du noch da weil ich muss die leier nicht jetzt runter leiern wenn du
nicht mehr da bist bist du noch da kicks le le keks wahrscheinlich nicht le keks xx aber
es können auch le keks sein wirstest du mal einen clip machen wo du es erklärst ja ich
sollte da vielleicht sogar mal ein video dazu machen
kannst immer leute erwähnen wenn sie was im chat geschrieben haben auch wenn sie nicht
mehr da sind also die frage war hallo gute tips um in programmieren einzusteigen ja also
das erste was man sich überlegen muss ist also das erste was man sich überlegen muss
ist was will man machen weil das entscheidet ganz erheblich was man lernen muss also sprich
möchte zum beispiel website machen möchte man windows desktop anwendung machen möchte
man apps machen oder was auch immer also das ist erstmal die grundsätzliche sache die
man sich fragen muss was möchte man machen und gibt es vielleicht schon irgendwelche
probleme die man lösen will also gibt es irgendwie ideen die man hat die einen gerade
nerven die man ändert wo man was für entwickeln möchte da hat man zumindest schon so gewisses
ziel vor augen und wenn man sich das überlegt hat dann kann man sich passende technologie
raussuchen wenn man zum beispiel sagt ok ich mache gerne windows desktop anwendung da kommt
man um dotnet nicht drum herum da kommt man um c-sharp dotnet und ja da wird es schwierig
weil windows und GUI technologien ist so ein thema für sich nicht drum herum allerdings
hat man mit dotnet generell auch gute basics für alles andere so wenn man webseiten machen
möchte dann muss man sich früher oder später mit javascript html beschäftigen css und
auch irgendeine backend geschichte also kriege ich was liefert die webseiten aus ja möchte
man irgendwelche modernen ai sonstige geschichten machine learning sachen machen oder vielleicht
auch bisschen eher richtung linux scripting sonst was gehen dann sollte man sich auf jeden
fall mal peisen angucken so und wenn man so durch das mal unabhängig davon was man machen
will würde ich sagen welche sachen lernen welche sachen bieten sich an zu lernen also
mein persönlicher favorit ist kein geheimnis c-sharp dotnet so nächste sache die sich auch
wunderbar zum einstieg eignet ist peisen da gibt es so viele tutorials und hilfen dazu
webcasts wots kostenlose bücher peisen ist aktuell eines der angesagten sprachen schlechthin
und das dritte ist früher hätte ich gesagt ruby sollte man sich auch mal angucken aber
ruby ist echt auf dem absteigenden ast auf was ich schade finde weil ruby gefällt mir
eigentlich von der sprache ziemlich gut oder das dritte im bunde ist was man sich angucken
sollte ist javascript also dort net z-sharp peisen javascript und dann wenn man mal ein
bisschen was abgedrehtes machen will kann man sich auch ein bisschen ein bisschen linux
shell angucken aber zum einstieg würde ich mir eine dieser drei sachen aussuchen unabhängig
je nachdem davon was ich machen will dort net z-sharp peisen oder javascript und über
kurz oder lang wird man eh alle drei sachen sich mal angucken meine lieblings kombination
ist ja wenn es um web anwendung geht dort net backend und javascript vue js frontend
das ist aber geschmackssache glaube ich war gar nicht mehr da aber hat er noch mehr interessiert
so erstmal kurz hier das chicken angucken übrigens habt ihr schon das beste meme vom
discord gesehen hab ich echt kaputt gelacht als das einer gepostet hat das ist ja gar
nicht von mir ich hab so ein bisschen besser lesbar gemacht und wer ist big brain genug
und er kennt den fehler aber erstmal finde ich fand ich übelst lustig ich glaube der
tommy hat tommy k hat auch gepostet auf dem discord war das übelst lustig wer findet
den fehler eine vor ist halt ganz gut ja gut das ist offensichtlich
jeder fehler ist das ist mir auch erst nachdem ich es kopiert hab et et kann man muss man
nicht nee kein plan man mit sanitäter als beruf kann ja nicht jeder alles wissen ich
bin froh dass es leute gibt die sanitäter werden
so zumindest ums mal ganz kurz zu machen der eigentliche fehler ist dass die logik komplett
anders ist hier unten weisen wir je nachdem auf was wir den switch machen image einen
wert zu hier nach der schleife ist image immer 199 119 genau das lasse ich gelten weil du
hast das bestimmt erst geschrieben also wir haben das ich habe parallel zu dem gesagt
was du geschrieben hast das hat ja ein paar sekunden genau das ist das eigentlich das
ist der eigentliche fehler stimmt nämlich überhaupt nicht was das steht ist vollkommen
verkehrt eigentlich müsste da eher noch leider müsste noch ein if drinne sein so nach dem
motto also man kann die vorschleife kann man komplett weglassen und einfach schreiben
image gleich prio was auch immer die variable ist auf die hier geswitcht wird und davor
müsste man auch im if machen if kleiner 120 oder so wenn es case bis 120 geht also eigentlich
ist es verkehrt verkehrt was da drin steht aber trotzdem nicht dass du trotzdem übrigens
lustig genau er erkennt oben dass es falsch ist und unten das funktioniert das hat jemand
auf dem discord gepostet das scheint wirklich legit live code zu sein erst einmal ich muss
jetzt die hähnchen fertig angucken und endlich mal mein brötchen essen
ich sehe aber echt gut aus das sieht echt gut aus
gleich macht er
das schmeckt glaube ich echt gut
niffel king ihr seid nicht die einzigen die solche dinger gebastelt haben jeder oder
die meisten die angefangen haben mit programmieren das erste geht mal in euch leute und sagt
mir mal im chat gleich ob ich recht habe trulul weh also die meisten haben mit folgendem
programm eingefangen angefangen abfrage in der kommando zeile bitte geben sie eine
zahl ein das war das erste was ihr programmiert habt bitte geben sie eine zahl ein und dann
je nachdem wie die übung weiter ging zahleraten oder sowas aber das erste was die was die
meisten leute programmiert haben ist diese übung bitte geben sie ein ja hello world
leute okay hello world mal außen vor also ich glaube bei den meistens diese aufgabe
ist so 0815 dass die irgendwie jeder lehrer auch bringt so nach dem motto bitte geben
sie eine zahl ein trulul weh carol robot hat das habe ich nie gemacht aber guck mal
die brennen gleich die hähnchen hier hinten was ist chat was ist das beste subway sub
was ist das beste subway sub
chicken teriyaki chili beef and cheese teriyaki also chicken teriyaki finde ich auch gut
aber prime sub prime sub ist das beste sub das stimmt
ich meinte aber gar kein gar kein money debate sondern ernsthaft sub des tages ja captain
peng das mache ich auch sub des tages über das mache ich auch immer ich war aber schon
eine ganze weile nicht mehr da was habe ich sonst auch immer gemacht außer wenn es meatball
gab meatball mag ich nicht oder gibt es glaube ich auch gar nicht mehr mochte mochte kaum
einer freitag ist immer tuner italien bmp mein lieblings ist steak and cheese das hat
auch jemand geschrieben hier ich glaube da wolle 1508 steak and cheese subway beste und
als soße mexikan die die nicht mehr so heißt übrigens nicht mehr mexikan southwest heißt
mittlerweile was das hier für einen kotz stein ist aber kein doch das ist steak steak
and cheese mexikan southwest beste exzellent keine extra käse keine extra fleisch die
die labern dich ja immer voll extra käse extra extra fleisch das fragen die so als
würde es nichts extra kosten dabei ist das viel zu teuer ich war schon ewig nicht mehr
beim subway aber ich bin nicht mehr zum subway gegangen weil das subway in frankfurt zugemacht
hat der bei uns in der nähe war und der andere der war nicht gut bei dem anderen bin ich
zwei drei mal hin und hatte danach immer übelst schiss und dann bin ich nicht mehr hin ach
ja und für für alle ökos kann man die dinge auch in so einem rap nehmen aber wer will
sowas schon keine ahnung was es mit ökos zu tun es gibt ja auch die leute die beim burger
salaten burger ohne fleisch und in eisbergsalat nehmen da fack das ist eine kombination eisbergsalat
gibt's wirklich ja ja genau hier die übrigens zu denen bin ich immer gerne gegangen
zu denen bin ich immer richtig gerne gegangen fletschers burger frankfurt allerdings die
haben vor drei oder vier wochen also der der eine bei uns hier um die ecke der ist hat
eh der ist eh dicht da war gammelfleisch oder so keine ahnung moment war aber gar nicht
der wo es der münchner münchner straße da fack das ist nicht der hier keine ahnung
zumindest der in der münchner straße der ist eh dicht gemacht worden der originale
fletschers burger weil keine ahnung gammelfleisch ich weiß es nicht so das problem ist jetzt
ich bin da immer gerne hingegangen aber seit ein paar wochen sind die der meinung es gibt
nur noch veggie burger die haben keine normalen burger mehr die haben nur noch veggie burger
das war für mich dann halt so wo ich mir gedacht habe ne das ist nicht so meins ja jedem
was ihm schmeckt ok aber veggie veggie veggie burger only muss nicht sein jetzt machen wir
lieber über den kokona programm an ich hab mal ich hab mal ein beyond meat burger gegessen
der war gar nicht übel ist schwer zu glauben dass ne burger nur veggie ja steht doch hier
guck sensationell burger ohne fleisch schmeckt wie fleisch nur viel besser ist gesünder
besser für die umwelt menü menü gebatet gibt es nicht mehr äh die haben doch kein
fleisch mehr äh oder doch moment dann ist es doch nicht nur veggie dann hat er mir
misst erzählt und ich hab euch mit setzten gebatet leute ich hätte wetten können das
ist nur noch nur noch veggie ich hab das ich war da nämlich selbstsicher mit letztes bloß
einer geschrieben so nach dem auto stell dir vor fleisch verkauft nur noch vegan oder
nur noch veggie und ich habe ihm das geklaut aber das stimmt nicht die werbung ist veggie
aber ansonsten haben die noch ganz normal fleisch ja jetzt wo du es sagst es ist auch
echt schwer zu glauben weil es gab letztens erst die news dass ähm einige veggie only
leden dicht gemacht haben weil es sich nicht so gut verkauft wäre ja komplett entgegen
dem was jetzt der flechers burger macht kann jetzt erstmal erst mal checken
also wie gesagt ich habe ja mal vor einer ganzen weile so ein beyond meat burger das
sieht das sieht wirklich gut aus so ein beyond meat burger gegessen das ging das ging das
ging schon irgendwo als burger durch ja man muss ja auch ehrlich mal sagen so wie bei
bei vielen leden der burger gemacht ist ist das fleisch meistens eh so gepresst und so
trocken und so durch dass das ohne problem auch gegen den fleischersatz sein könnte
wenn der rest wenn die restlichen sachen die drauf sind stark genug schmecken
excellent poggers so ich habe immer noch ein toastbrot das kann nicht sein ich habe
fast nichts gefuttert die hauen aber raus hier
ein stress kochen der willst aber wissen jetzt letztens hat er erst eine schnee schiebe masch
schnee schieber in lego gebaut dann hat er eine heu roller in lego gebaut und jetzt hat
er noch ein heu zusammenführer ich weiß nicht wie man das auf deutsch nennt gebaut das
ist lustig das kannst du anschauen ne kenne ich schon aber schon geguckt übrigens letztens
hat irgend ein video gepostet das habe ich mir vorhin angeguckt das war wirklich lustig
ich weiß nicht mehr wer es gepostet hat aber das ist so dermaßen bescheuert irgendwo dass
ich es eigentlich ganz lustig fand falls das hier war ja genau
jetzt wird es nicht wirklich aber es wird immer besser
ich habe also eine so genannte dose und gehe dann mal aus dem 60 volt muss ich ja jetzt
irgendwie 240 das heißt ich schalte in diesem stepper der 5 prole hat schalte ich 4 prole
3 dann kriege ich 240 volt und benutze jetzt den erdungskontakt als rückleiter jetzt habe
ich also nicht das verschaltet habe hier an dem stecker das ist ein sogenannter ce 125
amperestecker habe ich also 240 volt das langt natürlich noch nicht um auto zu laden der
nächste adapter der macht jetzt folgendes hier passiert jetzt folgendes da habe ich
jetzt die drei fasen erzeugt die wir brauchen also dreimal 240 volt ja der mit gerechnet
hat hat jetzt gemerkt wir haben ja vier mal 1000 watt hier aus dem stecker geholt die
haben wir jetzt hier quasi per vier facht also wir haben 4000 watt und daraus mache
ich jetzt mit diesem stecker mache ich bei 240 3 fasen wenn demnächst so eine vermittelungsstelle
in die luft fliegt wisst ihr warum das ist natürlich nicht funktioniert nur mal so das
falls irgendjemand auf die bescheuerte idee kommen sollte ja natürlich funktioniert
das so nicht habe ich dann anliegen dreimal 240 volt mit 4000 aber ich habe ja immer noch
kein drehstrom also brauche ich den nächsten adapter weil ich muss jetzt ja eins tun was
ganz wichtig ist ich muss ja jetzt sehen dass ich aus diesem normalen wechselstrom drehstrom
mache und die dichtung lassen wir mal weg so dazu ist dann der nächste adapter da und
dieser adapter macht jetzt folgendes gibt es leute die da auch auf reinfallen garantiert
es gibt auch leute es gibt auch leute die die telegram und whatsapp gruppe kommen in einer
um in einer woche millionär zu werden gibt es auch leute die machen das nach dafür dass
ich erstens den fasenwinkel von 120 grad kriege den fucking was die faktor 3 es schaffe
mir ein vernünftiges stabiles drehstrom netz rauszukriegen hier auf diesem stecker liegen
also jetzt gute 12 kw an wenn wir das gleich ausprobieren drauf ich muss ja jetzt den
tesla da glüht der switch bei der telekom das heißt wir müssen ja auch die tesla norm
kommen also auf ce 16 ampere deswegen haben wir 32 ampere auf 16 die müssen wir da mal
rein stecken jetzt könnten wir entweder an diesem adapter könnten wir entweder mit diesem
stecker da sind vier schubus dran könnten wir drei e-fahrzeuge jeweils 16 ampere das ist
alles aus der telefondose du meinst das klappt jetzt wirklich ja wir müssen jetzt noch eben
die telekom dose da in betrieb nehmen das aber kein problem ich habe da ja meinem trabo
habe ich den telekom anschluss das kein ding das kriegen wir hin und meinst du die telekom
hat nichts dagegen was soll die telekom dagegen haben die mehr merken sie es nicht und haben
die so viel strom und die sind so riesig das kann doch kein problem sein für die telekom
jetzt überlegt mal wenn der aus der telefondose so viel rausbekommt dann könnte er doch jetzt
überlegt aber jetzt big brain dann könnte er doch an sie neben dass er sein auto lädt
noch drei weitere telefondosen betreiben der würde dann quasi die energie verdreifachen
der macht dann aus einer telefondose ein ladekabel für das auto und drei weitere telefondosen
wo da noch mal drei leute laden können das ist ich würde sagen klima klima wandel und
energie wende gelöst die telefonen brauchen ja auch strom ja und die merken gar nicht
wenn da jetzt das alles weg geht das kriegt ihr mit glaube ich nicht das ja keine zähler
zwischen nichts die sollen die das merken dass das kabel nicht beschädigt wird findest
du das nicht ein bisschen wuchtig was du da gebaut hast ich liebe adapter geht das auch
mit power over ethernet na klar da hast du zwar nur 48 voll da brauchst du noch einen
zweiten adapter und dann ist gut ein ganz unauffälliger schnitt ein ganz unauffälliger
schnitt den schnitt sieht man gar nicht da ist gar nicht auffällig
jetzt können wir noch ein bisschen mehr kommen aber wir sind sehr sehr weit weg vom netzknotenpunkt
der telekom da verlieren wir halt bei der dünnen leitung bisschen was aber so können wir in
zukunft unsere autos laden oder wir könnten jetzt auch drei autos ranhängen mit 230 volt
da habe ich den adapter ja auch für da die vermittlungsstelle glüht irgendwo sitzt
der telekom support mensch und fragt sich warum brennt bei uns die komische die die
nächstgelegene verteiler box natürlich funktioniert das nicht der erste satz ist ja schon blödsinn
wie er das errechnet also es wollte mal ampere und nicht durch das fängt ja schon mal daran
da geht es ja schon mal los aber ich fand das trotzdem lustig deswegen hatte ich gestern
hohen ping ja das ist das problem wenn das wenn das wenn das mehr leute machen dann leiden
natürlich die anderen dies nicht machen drunter also klar das daran wenn deine ping probleme
gelegen haben und jetzt überlegt er erste mal wie man das ganze vielleicht noch mit
starlink verbinden könnte ich mein warum warum macht man es eigentlich so kompliziert und
macht er irgendwelche satelliten oder so die dann dann funken man könnte doch einfach
von jedem satellit ein kabel runter hängen lassen wo man sich dann anschließen kann
eigentlich eigentlich kein problem ja dann hast du strom dann hast du strom und internet
aus dem gleichen kabel ich würde sagen das sollten wir uns patentieren lassen warum hat
das noch keiner gemacht fragt man sich da geht nicht wegen den bäumen naja wir sind
dann so klima und und strom effizient da brauchen wir keine bäume mehr kann ich alles haben
es geht nicht alles gleichzeitig ja aber da muss man in die satelliten auch steckdosen
einbauen ja oder der tae dose haben wir jetzt ja gesehen porgas musik hier das ist die final
fantasy 6 intro musik als eines der besten final fantasy musik stöge finde ich so jetzt
haben wir uns doch ordentlich schwachsinn angeguckt das ist so nice man hört halt dass
super nintendo ist und das auch so brauche ich was bisschen längeres ich hoffe in acht
stunden sind wir bei der kampagne durch wird aber langer streben wenn ich acht stunden
in der kampagne durch sein will das wird glaube ich nix naja also immer so ich muss jetzt
noch tatsächlich ein stück obst essen weil gesund und so was so welche kampagne naja
ich habe gesagt ich will mal neuen pass auf exile character machen ich muss euch mal kurz
ausschalten und gucken ob ich überhaupt mein login da habe hoffentlich kann ich einloggen
wenn nicht habe ich ein problem kann mich nicht einloggen ok kann mich nicht einloggen
ist doof kriege ich erstmal passport raus ja ja leute ich würde sagen da muss ich mal
kurz ein viertel stunde auf mit warn nee ich könnte mein key pass aufmachen im zweiten
rechner allerdings habe ich mein key pass in letzter zeit nicht mehr gesunken und ich
habe das pass auf exile passport erst seit paar tagen im key pass drinnen deswegen gar
nichts bisher sehe ich auf dem zweiten rechner angucken oder ich nehme die password vergessen
funktion ich mache ich mache die password vergessen funktion die password vergessen
funktion dieser der desktop sieht nur so aus weil der chat mich debatet dazu ganz viele
emotes rein zu machen gefällt aber vielleicht vielleicht ist der desktop so erträglicher
mein wo sie mal stehen geblieben hier irgendwo so pass auf exile.com und jetzt erstmal passport
reset machen rechtsklick symbole ausblenden sowas geht echt jetzt gibt es nicht sowas
geht bei microsoft nicht rechtsklick symbole ausblenden sowas gibt es da nicht doch das
geht echt wo wo wo wo wo geht das ah ach guck mal da oh nee da kann man aber auch nicht
da kann man aber auch nicht markieren auf dem desktop ich brauche ich brauche diese
markierfunktion auf dem desktop ich nehme neben dem dass ich immer eins in die zwischenablage
mache ist desktop markieren markieren mein zweiter tick den ich unter windows habe das
geht ja ohne symbole nicht und jetzt was mache ich denn jetzt was mache ich jetzt
so logins ich glaube ich habe mein passport wieder gefunden logins and passwords pass
off exile hier moment vorher so chat ich mache ich mal kurz aus ich will jetzt nämlich kein
passport leaken so hoffe ich dass es funktioniert wenn es nämlich nicht
fack das password stimmt nicht ok leute ich bin in ich bin in fünf minuten einfach wieder
on bin fünf minuten wieder am start da machen wir weiter und dann wenn die pass of exile
kampagne durchgespeed rund so schnell wie es geht weil ich unbedingt noch einen eigentlich
diesen dritter character haben will informatiker hassen diesen trick ja ich bin gleich wieder
da alle die pass of exile gucken wollen die season die session die season ist schon bald
wieder vorbei nö geht doch eigentlich harvest poe das läuft nur erst seit einem monat die
ist noch nicht mal zur hälfte rum oder sagen wir so höchstens zur hälfte rum die geht
noch ein zwei monate das ist auch schon das ende ne also es sind nicht alle so schnell
dass die jeden tag 10 10 stunden kreiten oder so muss man ein paar andere sachen machen
so alle die pass of exile gucken wollen können da bleiben ich bin fünf minuten wieder da
und da mache ich mir einen neuen character ich habe aber schon die passenden items dafür
und ich bin mir noch nicht sicher wie wir das machen also entweder probiere ich es mal
ohne items wie gut ich durchkomme oder ich ziehe mir gleich die op level items an und
gut ist das war mal schauen bis gleich fünf minuten wieder da